Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
Đỗ Bảo Nam và đốt
video ngày nay Đỗ Bảo Nam Block sẽ chia
sẻ với bạn cách giãn chữ trong word áp
dụng trên mọi phiên bản watch
để chỉnh khoảng cách giữa các chữ trong
word thì bạn chỉ cần thực hiện theo 3
bước đơn giản nhưng ở trên màn hình
Hoa bây giờ mình sẽ thực hiện để mua cho
các bạn
bước thứ nhất bạn Bôi đen phần văn bản
cần dáng chữ trà sữa đây mình sẽ Bôi đen
hai đoạn văn bản đầu tiên
sao đâu bước từ nay bạn mở hộp phải
không Bạn có thể dùng phím tắt là can
trong cộng d hoặc Click vào cái icon mũi
tên trong bóc Phong
Ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ được vào ai tuần này
khi hộp thoại phong hiện ra bạn Click
vào Tab envon
và ở ở đây sinh này bạn có thể
chỉnh cái khoảng cách ở trong cái mục
bay bạn khỏe tăng Ví dụ như 01
pt02 PT
3456 trở hạn đơn vị tính ở đây là PT
sau khi bạn đá chỉnh cái khoảng cách
giữa các chữ xong bạn chỉ cần kích vào
ok
như vậy bạn thấy ở hai cái đoạn đầu tiên
mình mô đen khoảng cách giữa các chữ sẽ
rộng hơn so với giai đoạn thứ ba này
và như vậy Ở nội dung video vừa rồi đâu
Bảo Nam vừa chia sẻ nhanh với bạn cách
giãn chữ trong word Nếu bạn Nếu bạn có
những câu hỏi cần được hỗ trợ bạn anh
comment trực tiếp ở phía dưới video này
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo
Ừ
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn nhấp chuột vào nay và chia sẻ
video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam bất đồng thời
Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam lúc
bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký và
chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video cũng từ đỗ bà Nam và Đốc Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam rồi lúc
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam club.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blog để xem
thêm các video hữu ích như thủ thuật máy
tính tay Producer
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bà Nam vào lúc chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết thôi mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
Hôm nay bạn ở các video tiếp theo